قال مدير الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه ان
الوكاله ركبت لاول مره اجهزه مراقبه
للتخصيب في منشاتو الايرانيتين وفي طهران
قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان تقرير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذي صدر
اليوم يثبت ان طهران تفضل دائما التعاون
مع الوكاله من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ان ايران تبقى الخطر الاكبر على
اسرائيل ولا يمكن لها ان تمتلك سلاحا
نوويا من مقر الوكاله في فيينا معنا مراسل
الجزيره ايمن الزبير ومعنا من طهران مراسل
الجزيره عمر هواش ومن واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم وابدا معك ايمن وما جاء
على لسان الوكاله وموصف بانه تطور ايجاري
في العلاقه بين الوكاله وبين ايران
بالفعل عبد القادر السواء في الافتتاحيه
لمجلس المحافظين او في الندوه الصحفيه
يمكن الحديث عن اجواء ايجابيه وعن حصول
تقدم بشهاده مدير وكاله الطاقه الذريه
الذي تحدث عن العوده الى تنفيذ البيان
المشترك وذلك عبر خطوات فعليه ربما اهمها
هي اعاده تثبيت الكاميرات لاول مره في
منشاتي
وهذه الخطوه تعتبرها وكاله الطاقه الذريه
ضروريه لمتابعه انشطه ايران النوويه
الوكاله ايضا تحدثت في هذا التقرير عن
عوده او عن ان ايران منحت معطيات حول ما
يعرف بالمنشات السريه وقالت انها بصدد
التحقق من دقه هذه المعلومات في الشق
الاخر ايضا
مدير العام لوكاله طاقه تحدث عن ارتفاع
مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه
60% الى 100 كيلوغرام ولكن بدا اللافتا
عندما قال ان تخصيب اليورانيوم لا يعتبر
نشاطا محظورا وذلك ربما للرد على
الانتقادات التي توجه للوكاله التي تتهم
من بعض الاطراف من انها الان غيرت
معاييرها ولم تعد صارمه هنا جروسي تحدث عن
الدور التقني للوكاله وانها لا تستطيع فرض
عقوبات لمزيد من المعطيات هذا هذه الكلمه
لجروسي
ستاندر
فيما يتعلق بالمعايير انا اؤكد اننا لم
نخفف من معاييرنا ابدا نحن ملتزمون بهذه
المعايير ونطبقها في عمليه معقده ونحن
صارمون من الناحيه التقنيه حازمون ولكننا
عادلون في الوقت نفسه لم نخفف من معاييرنا
لاسباب سياسيه نتفهم وجود تلك المواقف
السياسيه ولكننا لا ننحاز لها
تفضل التعاون مع الوكاله كما جعل الانسان
او تصريح ادلبه مسؤول للجزيره
والوكاله خلال الفتره الماضيه القضيه
الاولى كانت مساله تخسيب اليورانيو بنسبه
فوق 80 في المئه في منشاه فوردو اليوم
مدير عام الوكاله غروسي قال ان هذه القضيه
قد اغلقت كذلك التطور الايجابي الثاني
عندما تحدث عن تركيب كاميرات جديده في بعض
المواقع مثل فوردو ومثل ناطنز لكن النقطه
الهامه ان هذه الكاميرا سوف تعمل بصيغه
اوف لاين اي انها لا تنقل المعلومات الى
الوكاله الدوله الطاقه الذريه طهران سوف
تحتفظ بتسجيلات كاميرات المراقبه الى حين
عوده الاطراف الى الاتفاق النووي النقطه
الثالثه هي النقطه مهمه اشاره بان الموقع
اباد الذي هو يصنف ضمن المواقع التي قالت
الوكاله انها عثرت فيها على اثار
لليورانيوم وانها مواقع غير معلنه يقول
بان هذه المعلومات قد تكون صحيحه لكن هذا
الملف لم يغلق يضاف الى ملف موقعين اثنين
تقول الوكاله انها لا تزال عالقه بين
طهران والوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه احمد
هزيم وزير خارج الامريكيه يقول ايران لم
تمتلك قنبله نوويه في تصريح قبل قليل
نعم عبد القادر كان في اثناء كلمته امام
مؤتمر ايباك الدعم لاسرائيل هنا في
الولايات المتحده وجاء من منطلق
تقييم الولايات المتحده وتقييم الوزير
بلينكن لان الخطر الاكبر الذي يواجه
اسرائيل هو ايران هو سلوكيات ايران هو دعم
ايران لكل من حزب الله وحركه حماس في قطاع
غزه وان هذا يعني ان ايران لا يجب ان يسمح
لها بامتلاك سلاح نووي ومن الولايات
المتحده ستعمل على تاكيد ذلك لكنه اشار
ايضا في معرض هذا الحديث بان الوسيله
الافضل من وجهه نظر امريكيه هي
الدبلوماسيه لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي لكن هذه الدبلوماسيه مدعومه ايضا
بضغوط اقتصاديه
باظهار قوه الردع العسكريه الامريكيه لكنه
عاد وقال ان لم تنفع الدبلوماسيه في منع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي فان الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن كان قد امر بوضع جميع
الخيارات على الطاوله لتحقيق هذا الهدف اي
حرمان ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي بمعنى ان
الولايات المتحده الداعمه لاسرائيل تحدث
في معرضه في معرض حديثه عن ما تقدمه
اسرائيل من دعم خصوصا للقبه الحديديه
وخصوصا لمنظومات
المضاده للصواريخ مساله الملف النووي
الايراني بالنسبه للولايات المتحده او
امتلاك ايران لسلاح نووي مساله خط احمر
تعهد الرئيس بايدن بان لا تتجاوزوا ايران
وان الولايات المتحده ستبذل كل بما وسعها
وكل ما لديها من اوراق بما في ذلك القوه
العسكريه لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي
نستمع الى هذا الجزء من كلمته امام ايباد
نحن مستمرون بالاعتقاد بان الدبلوماسيه هي
افضل طريقه فعاله ومستدامه لمنع ايران من
امتلاك سلاح نووي بما في ذلك العقوبات
ومتابعه الضغوطات واذا رفضت ايران طريق
الدبلوماسيه فقد اوضح الرئيس بايدن بان كل
الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله للتاكد من
عدم امتلاك ايران للسلاح النووي احمد هزيم
من واشنطن من طهران وايمن الزبير من مقر
الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه شكرا جزيلا
لكم